[Musique]
les musiciens de pink floyd ont joué
partout sur la planète mais c'est à
montréal
ils ont donné le 6 juillet 1977 au stade
olympique
un des concerts les plus importants de
l'histoire du rock
[Musique]
c'est parce que c était le début de
dollars j'étais là et à ça me donne la
chair de poule
un imposant système de sécurité a été
mis sur pied pour parer à toute
éventualité pour ce que l'on le jour de
ce concert qui sera le premier présenté
au stade olympique
la ville est en état d' alerte et la
sécurité est renforcée dès le début du
spectacle la foule estimée à près de 78
mille personnes et bruyante et
indiscipliné il avait de la violence
sentait qu'il y avait des gens comme tu
disais plus tôt
je fais beaucoup de monde qui avait bu
beaucoup et des pétards des feux
d'artifice des comoni - comme tout des
machines common alors c'est eux-mêmes
leur waters j'étais terrorisée après 30
minutes de concert le cas où ces temps
ci fit un admirateur dérange le groupe
le bassiste roger waters se passe et ils
crachent au visage d'un spectateur del
inca sur cet enregistrement on entendiez
que le climat est tendu
en entrevue que 40 ans plus tard roger
waters regrette le geste qu'il a posé
mais il se console en se disant que si
ce crachat qui lui a inspiré le mur de
droite
un album sur l'aliénation à gauche
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui le ranger interprète
en concert des chansons de l'album dow
qui s'est vendue au fils du temps à près
de 30 millions d'exemplaires
[Musique]
mais rien ne pourra remplacer le concert
de 1977 pour gates ans est arnaud et
pierre bordure des événements pendant
cette soirée qui ont vraiment qui sont
restés avec moi
un show inoubliable face à produire plus
jamais
[Applaudissements]
ici oui fait depuis mai radio canada
montréal
[Musique]